here's video of cbs's Michelle Miller
suggesting that Florida is Banning books
that have black characters in them hint
it's not true
an important footnote to the story
soulway has been banned in some Florida
schools and might be banned Statewide
under the stop woke act Harrison says
it's disappointing and upsetting but she
will continue to work on stories with
diverse characters the fact that soulway
a character trying to find her identity
and be okay with it would be banned
because she's a black character she just
couldn't believe it but these are
stories for everyone when she was
describing big I was like oh my God I
wish that had existed when I was a kid I
love that story
love the vibrancy of the work I mean it
just jumps off the page yeah
God and that white guy my God I'm going
to keep my job because it jumps off the
page I'm white I'm hanging on by a
thread over here unless I say something
patterning so of course
it is not true what they just said there
are a little context let's give you some
context uh Solway the book Banning it
appears that and this is according to
Yahoo news that none of the books have
been banned but some books have been
temporarily pulled while they are
reviewing some of this literature right
because there's also all of these books
where they are literally teaching fourth
graders how to give hand jobs which is
generally not thought of as a good thing
if you want a little more context about
what Solway actually is uh It Is by
Lupita nuyango and vashti Harrison it's
a children's book about colorism and
self-esteem a dark-skinned Kenyan girl
named Solway which means star wishes she
had lighter skin like her sister until a
magical journey changes her life and
helps her see beauty okay so I don't
know everything about the freaking book
but Brian Griffin who is uh Governor
desantis's press secretary well here's
what he had to say about it America
here's Michelle Miller lying to your
face on CBS with zero accountability
from her co-hosts or network no book in
Florida is banned Statewide this is the
official representative of this anthis
and no book would be permissibly removed
from a classroom for having a black
character they want you to be
misinformed so do you see how they do
this what they're really trying to make
this sound like if you watch the clip
that we just played it's somehow it's
because she's black and they don't want
you hearing about a black character in a
book they are looking into some books to
see has critical race Theory leaked into
this stuff has this genderqueer lunacy
leaked into this stuff are they teaching
neo-racism to kids so they are looking
into some things which actually is I
would say at this point if you believe
in State education at any level and I
think there's a good debate to have
there whether we should have public
schools at all anymore but if you
believe that they should then the state
has to decide well what is appropriate
for kids so they're looking into some
things
[Music]